good evening tonight remembering a soul
that will never be forgotten a balloon
release Candlelight vigil for 26 year
old Tabitha tazi good evening I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus Metro Police
say tazi was shot and killed over a week
ago by her boyfriend during an argument
friends family gathering tonight at The
Trails Park in Summerlin to honor her a
news now reporter Madison Kimbrough was
there spoke to friends about the type of
person Tabitha was
yeah Brian about 75 people showed up for
Tabitha sharing how impactful she was
for their lives and in her life and also
what they knew about this relationship
that allegedly ended it all right
Tabitha tazi remember Tuesday night at
an emotional vigil say something for me
family and friends sharing what she
meant to them and what they missed
everyone that she even talked to protect
what can we do like they knew that she
made them smile like from the inside out
always empowered them Tabitha was 26
years old when she was shot and killed
over a week ago the prime suspect her
boyfriend 26 year old Oswaldo Perez
Sanchez who has since gone missing those
close to the couple admit there were red
flags in the relationship but they never
expected this he's dangerous you know I
would have never seen it seen it coming
you know we trusted this man I do feel
like it was more of maybe an obsession
Tabitha's mother did not want to speak
on camera as she ended the night with
the crowd embracing her surrounded in
candles and releasing balloons
we heard over and over how Tabitha's
light shined brighter than most a light
that will not be dimmed in their hearts
and their memories she was very special
to me
and everyone here I believe it hurts to
to see her leave this way she reached
such a broad group of people
um
literally everyone who met her loved her
Tabitha was a poet and some of her
poetry was rolled into the balloons that
were released tonight now as for her
funeral that will take place tomorrow
afternoon it's open to the public it's
going to be held at the Palms Northwest
Mortuary again open to the public to
join reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now